c'est le seul gros et j'espère que vous
allez bien aller dans les prochaines
semaines vont donc décrypter ensemble le
programme de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve pour décrypter le
programme à dalgo en dix mesures reliées
au passage je vais le dire à chaque fois
mais évidemment je parfois représenter
tout le programme de hidalgo l'idée
c'est donc de vous donner le meilleur
aperçu possible en tout cas pour ne pas
louper les décryptages des programmes de
tous les candidats ainsi que les
interviews de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle bat pour ça
vous abonner ou simplement à cette
chaîne youtube puisque les vidéos sorte
au fur et à mesure jusqu'au mois d'avril
bon alors pour commencer qui est anne
hidalgo elle a 62 ans elle est née en
espagne avant d'arriver en france à
l'âge de deux ans elle a commencé sa vie
professionnelle en tant qu'inspectrice
du travail elle a rejoint ensuite le
parti socialiste en 1994 et sa carrière
politique a véritablement démarré en
1997 à gauche donc en tant que
conseillère de l'actuel maire de lille
martine aubry et qui était à l'époque
ministre de l'emploi en 2001 elle est
devenue la première adjointe du maire ps
de paris de l'époque c'était bertrand
delanoë et puis elle s'est fait vraiment
connaître du grand public quand elle a
succédé justement à bertrand delanoë en
2014 devenant ainsi la première femme
maire de paris elle a d'ailleurs été
réélu en juin 2020 pour un second mandat
à la tête de la capitale il s'agit en
l'occurrence de la première candidature
d'ali d'algos à l'élection
présidentielle et on va donc voir
ensemble ces dix principales mesures
pour la france première mesure forte du
programme d'anne hidalgo elle souhaite
accorder le droit de vote dès l'âge de
16 ans et donc plus seulement à 18 ans
comme c'est le cas actuellement c'est
une mesure qui a aussi proposé notamment
par d'autres candidats à gauche il ya
notamment jean luc mélenchon ou encore
yannick jadot est à noter au passage
qu'elle veut aussi accorder le droit de
vote aux étrangers pour les élections
locales comme par exemple pour les
élections municipales deuxième mesure
majeure du programme dany d'algos elle
souhaite augmenter le smic donc le
salaire minimum de 15 % ce qui
correspond à une hausse d'environ 200
euros nets par mois donc le smic
s'élèverait à 1450 euros par mois au
lieu
2269 euros actuellement et l'idée
d'augmenter le salaire minimum c'est
portela aussi par pas mal de candidats à
gauche troisième mesure d'algos a
beaucoup fait parler ces derniers jours
c'est le versement de 5000 euros pour
tous les jeunes à leurs 18 ans sans
condition donc peu importe si les
parents sont riches ou pauvres par
exemple l'objectif affiché en versant
ses 5000 euros à 18 ans c'est d'aider à
financer des projets qu'ils soient
professionnels ou alors personnel sans
avoir besoin de justifier quoi que ce
soit on fait donc ce qu'on veut de cet
argent et si vous voulez en savoir plus
on en a parlé dans l'une de nos vidéos
d'actu du jour donc je vous mets un
petit lien en descriptions à noter au
passage que en plus de ses 5000 euros
anne hidalgo propose aussi un revenu
minimum jeunesse de 564 euros par mois
pour les jeunes qui sont les plus en
difficulté financièrement quatrième
mesure désormais anne hidalgo veut
augmenter le salaire des enseignants en
faisant en sorte que un professeur qui
débute gagne l'équivalent du salaire
d'un cadre débutant à bac + 5 ça donne
environ 2300 euros net par mois alors
que c'est environ 1700 euros nets
aujourd'hui est à noter au passage que
dans son livre une femme française qui
est sorti l'année dernière elle parlait
de doubler le salaire des enseignants
donc aujourd'hui ce n'est véritablement
plus le cas mais il ya tout de même une
augmentation qui est prévu cinquième
mesure on a parlé d'écologie maintenant
pour marquer l'importance de la lutte
contre le changement climatique
anne hidalgo veut que le numéro deux du
gouvernement soit un ministre ou une
ministre du climat de la biodiversité et
de l'économie c'est une mesure assez
symbolique ça veut dire concrètement que
il serait considéré comme le deuxième
ministre le plus important juste après
donc le premier ministre ali d'algos
veut aussi inscrire la lutte contre le
changement climatique dans la
constitution donc la loi suprême du pays
et c'est d'ailleurs l'une des mesures
phares de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qui est organisée en 2019 mais
il mesure qui n'a pas abouti car le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale ne se
sont pas mis d'accord pour l'inscrire
dedans l'autre mesure phare pour
l'environnement d'anne hidalgo c'est de
rétablir l'impôt sur la fortune c'est
impôts donc payé par les personnes les
plus riches qui a été supprimée par
emmanuel macron mais par contre est bien
elle souhaite le remplacer par un impôt
sur la fortune climatique concrètement
qu'est ce que c'est bien c'est un impôt
sur la fortune mais modulée en fonction
de l'impact environnemental des
placements financiers qui sont fait donc
par ces ménages les plus riches cette
idée comme ça de taxer les plus riches
en fonction de leur impact sur le climat
ça s'appuie notamment sur un rapport du
laboratoire des inégalités mondiales qui
indique que 10% des plus fortunés sont
responsables de la moitié des émissions
mondiales de co2 est à noter au passage
que cette mesure dit sf climat est
portée aussi par d'autres candidats à
gauche là aussi comme yannick jadot le
candidat du parti europe ecologie les
verts ou encore jean luc mélenchon de la
france soumise 7e mesure maintenant on
va parler de droits des femmes anne
hidalgo veut rétablir un ministère 100%
dédié aux droits des femmes c'est en
fait un ministère qui avait été
supprimée par emmanuel macron pour
devenir notamment un secrétariat d'état
fuyez bien un ministère plus large qui
comprend aussi la lutte contre les
discriminations et sur ce même thème
anne hidalgo souhaite adopter certaines
mesures appliquées en espagne à savoir
la formation des policiers des gendarmes
des magistrats la présence d'assistantes
sociales dans les commissariats ou
encore l'éloignement des conjoints ou ex
conjoints violents la huitième mesure
concerne la question du temps de travail
anne hidalgo veut rendre possible des
négociations en interne au sein des
entreprises donc pour travailler moins
de 35 heures par semaine en gros l'idée
serait de garder la base des 35 heures
de travail par semaine en france mais de
laisser la possibilité aux entreprises
éventuellement de faire - à noter que
cette question du temps de travail
divise énormément les candidats et ça
risque d'être un sujet majeur pour cette
campagne jorick mélenchon par exemple
veut rétablir les 35 heures sans
exception et même passer aux 32 heures
pour le travail de nuit notamment alors
que valérie pécresse à droite veut de
son côté augmenter le temps de travail
est passé à une base de 39 heures par
semaine 9e mesure désormais anne hidalgo
veut mettre en place une loi je cite
pour garantir le droit à une fin de vie
digne concrètement elle veut permettre à
ceux qui le souhaitent de pouvoir se
faire euthanasier légalement en france
donc de mettre fin à leur jour de
manière médical et encadré l'idée étant
notamment d'éviter que certains français
se rendent à l'étranger pour le faire en
tout cas logiquement le sujet de la fin
de vie est un sujet qui est complexe les
candidats d'ailleurs ont différentes
propositions et différentes visions sur
le sujet c'est un sujet qui vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à me le dire
dans les commentaires on aura pourquoi
pas l'occasion d'en faire une vidéo
dédiée pour comprendre concrètement ce
qu'il en est en france aujourd'hui à les
dernières mesures avant de passer aux
petites mesures supplémentaires à la fin
anne hidalgo veut créer un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
l'objectif serait donc de permettre aux
citoyens de réunir un nombre de
signatures fixée par la loi pour
organiser un référendum sur un sujet
sans avoir besoin de l'accord du
parlement ou encore du président c'était
une mesure qui était a notamment réclamé
par les gilet jaune et qui est également
présente notamment dans le programme de
jean luc mélenchon ou alors vous en
doutez peut pas détailler toutes les
mesures parce que comme pour les autres
candidats ce serait impossible et en
l'occurrence dans le programme de nidal
go et à près de 70 mesures mais en vrac
on pourrait aussi citer le fait que à
l'hidalgo propose la suppression de
parcours sub pour créer un nouveau
système de construire aux 650 mille
logements sociaux par an ou encore de
prolonger le congé paternité à 16
semaines contre quatre semaines
actuellement elle souhaite aussi mettre
en place une loi pour atteindre
l'égalité des salaires femmes hommes en
cinq ans en rendant notamment publique
la liste des entreprises qui ne
respectent pas cette égalité de salaire
pour donc leur imposer des pénalités sur
le plan énergétique elle va arriver à
100% d'énergies renouvelables aussi
rapidement que possible sans construire
de nouvelles centrales nucléaires et
enfin au niveau international elle a
affirmé à plusieurs reprises qu'elle
souhaitait mettre l'union européenne
vraiment au coeur de son projet voilà
donc pour le programme et les mesures
majeures d'anne hidalgo vous le savez
ont publié dans les prochains jours des
décryptages des programmes ainsi que des
interviews de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle l'idée étant
de vous aider le plus possible à
connaître concrètement ce que proposent
chacun des candidats n'hésitez pas
évidemment pour nous soutenir et ne pas
rater les vidéos suivantes à vous
abonner en descriptions jouer des petits
1 pour en savoir plus prenez soin de
vous et on se dit du coup à très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo